you see the ons data that came out a
couple of weeks ago that said for the
first time ever since records began
50.1 percent of women are childless by
30. so there are more women without
children at 30 than there are women with
children the first time well so this is
somebody clipped
a part of
one of my podcasts i believe it was
where i was talking about
what what our society does to 19 year
old women or 18 year old women 19 year
old women we just lie to them all the
time
you know the first lie is
there's nothing more important than your
career more or less by definition so
that's the first lie the second lie is
there will be nothing more important to
you
in your life than your career
so that's the second lie and then the
third lie is there should be nothing
more important in your life than their
career so that's the third lie
and then
implicit in that is the idea that
children are a burden and that the idea
that women
should have children
is part of the oppressive patriarchy and
should be resisted and who are men to
tell me what i can do with my body and
hey fair enough and etc etc now
i've worked in female dominated
occupations my entire life i worked for
example i worked
as a daycare uh
worker
way back when that was like 19 probably
80 something like that and there were no
men doing that but i really liked kids
and so that was fun and i worked for
social services in alberta in the in the
child care department and uh then i've
been working as a psychologist
either training or as a psychologist
since then and that's been a female
dominated enterprise increasingly as the
years went by but even when i
was first
when i first entered it
so i
i'm in the post
female in the workplace generation
firmly
i never experienced the world
except as that and so i've watched women
progress through their professional
careers at every level of attainment
from the lowest to the highest
and observed what happened and
relatively
i would say bias free because i didn't
know
and
what i've seen is that as women progress
towards their
late 30s
no late 20s
they
there's a psychological transformation
and what happens is that they place less
emphasis on their career
and way more emphasis particularly on
having a child
and that really reaches a crisis point
around 29 or 30 for the vast majority of
women and and their attitude flips and
i've seen it very dramatically with many
women
and i suppose the most
signal single
most
uh
convincing
evidence of that i worked with
high-end lawyers in toronto for about 10
years
i was part of an organization we went to
law firms
high-end law firms and said
send us your most productive people
and we'll help them iron out whatever
wrinkles there might still be in their
life and the advantage to them is that
things will go better for them and the
advantage to you is they'll be even more
productive
and there's a good management dictum
which is pay the most attention to your
most productive people because they're
bringing in the bulk of your revenue
disproportionately and so i worked with
men and women who were at the peak of
their careers
in a very difficult enterprise
and so these were women who were
generally very attractive
well put together physically
pretty stable psychologically
extremely conscientious very very smart
and high achieving from like junior high
all the way through
high school university
law school
onto uh the top firms
rocketing up through the ranks full
partnership by the time they were 29 or
30 and all the law firms all the women
bailed out all of them the law firms
couldn't keep them
and i i was really and i talked to the
women a lot about a lot about this
because i was very interested in it
because i knew the law firms were
bending themselves over backwards and
tying themselves into knots trying to
retain these women because why wouldn't
they you know just just being greedy
capitalists is enough you know we don't
want to lose their high performing women
because they're performing at the
highest level and
they couldn't keep them the women wanted
to have nine to five jobs they wanted to
bind the job so they could have a life
and that was especially true once they
got interested in having a child or had
one and what what they really came to
was a very
uh interesting realization so
because they were highly conscientious
women they sort of did their duty and
and worked hard and diligently and
didn't pop their head up to ask
questions they're in junior high they
got their best grades they were in high
school they got the best grades and so
on all the way through
right till they reach partnership but
that's sort of an apogee right you hit
partnership in a senior law firm it's
like you're at you're at the top of your
profession
well then what
so then they looked around and they
thought
here i am with all these like
hyper competitive men
perfectly willing to work 80 hours a
week non-stop to stay at the top
what the hell are they doing because
that's the real question
what is it
what is it that characterizes this small
percentage of hyper-competitive men
it's not
you can assume that that's how everyone
should be but first of all that isn't
how everyone is or you can flip that and
say well there's only a small minority
of human beings that are willing to do
this to work flat out eight hours a week
i mean they're getting they're certainly
being paid for it let's make no mistake
about that but
what about the rest of life
well that's what the women asked
why am i doing this
and that's a great question well for men
there's a different answer than for
women it's a really different answer and
it isn't like the men are exactly
thinking this through it's it's more
like this is an integral part of male
motivation
the more successful you are as a man the
more women like you but the problem that
you have now is that
as women are getting
better educated with more employment
more state is more prestige they compete
themselves out of their ability to find
an attractive mate as women raise up
through the dominance hierarchy and this
is
competence competence hierarchy sorry
okay
who's going to tell women
the
equal access to opportunity that you
have recently just acquired
actually what that's doing is it's
making it more difficult for you to find
a mate that you're fundamentally
attracted to yeah well it it it does a
lot of things i mean it does provide
women with
a lot more
uh opportunity on the economic front it
does
decrease their dependency on their mate
in relationship to economic security and
educating educating women
countries that are willing to educate
women that's the best predictor of their
future economic success so if you look
at developing countries and you want to
find out what about a developing country
is most likely to predict the fact that
they will continue to thrive
economically it's their attitude towards
the education of women and but a couple
more things
women's educational status predicts
their children's educational status but
men's educational status doesn't so
that's also an important
multi-generational effect
i released a video i was going to
conclude that other story i released a
video
or someone released a clip of me talking
about some of the things we just talked
about
and it went out on youtube shorts and
it's got like five million views in a
month or something like that and the
comment section is unbelievably
vitriolic because every single comment
is vitriolic and it's all from women
it's like who is this old white bastard
telling us what we should do with our
bodies you know when i wasn't being
judgmental i was just saying exactly
what i said to you which is well i've
watched women
over the entire course of my life with i
would say an affectionate eye you know i
love my sister i love my wife i have a
daughter i love my mother i'm pretty
happy about women all things considered
i don't have an axe to grind in
relationship to how they should conduct
their lives i don't even know how they
should conduct their lives i've watched
what happens and i've also watched what
happens to women who hit 29 or 30 and
then can't conceive
and that is not a fate i would wish on
anyone it's awful and 30 percent of
couples fall into that 30 percent of
couples have difficulty conceiving
it's a lot and the probability that
you'll have difficulty conceiving
increases with age and so
you know
c'est la vie
and but it's very interesting to me to
see
how vitriolic those comments have been
and how how uniform that is because
usually on my youtube channel in
particular ninety-five percent of the
comments are positive and this is
completely the opposite of that
so and then so you brought this up at
the beginning you said fifty percent of
women now at thirty point fifty point
one childless by thirty yeah yeah well
you know
that's uh
that's not good that's a sign of
something profoundly wrong with the
entire culture at an extremely deep
level i don't think that
women need to take it as us trying to
tell women what they should or shouldn't
do but i think that it would be very
fair to say that you need to be an
incredibly unique woman to make it to 50
without a family and look back and think
yeah i did this right that's not to say
that those women aren't out there they
absolutely are i know some of them
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you